this campaign unique in American history
since at least the Civil War and if we
are fortunate unique for the next
thousand years has by and large been
framed by the media as the expression of
the anger of those who feel themselves
if not disenfranchised then at least
excluded from control of a nation their
fathers and grandfathers once dominated
because they had built the playing field
and had not merely tilted it towards
themselves but had filled the other end
with land mines to disempower the
minorities and the women the angry white
male Trump voter would rather burn it
down and accept Hillary Clinton the
angry white male Trump voter wants his
country back the angry white male Trump
voter to use their lunatic candidates
meaningless phrases wants to win and to
make America great again enough the
angry white male Trump voters are not
the only angry Americans right now in
fact they are not alone they are not a
majority and they're not even angriest
it is time for the media for the
Mussolini in makeup Trump for the world
to recognize that real Americans
liberals and conservatives driven
together in common defense of this
nation real Americans the ones who
believe in democracy and believe in
diversity and believe in innocence until
guilt be proven whether for a suspect or
the members of a religious group we are
angry too we have had enough of what
this man Trump has made us look like to
the world we have had enough of the
hatreds he has unleashed and the
apologists in the media who have not
stood up and called him what he is a
fascist who wants to end this democracy
we have had enough of every third thing
coming out of his mouth serving the
goals of the terrorists like Isis and
the rogue nations like Russia we have
had enough of every lie and excuse and
contradiction and him saying he was
smart and brilliant not to pay taxes
than his son insisting he has paid taxes
then his spokesman refusing to say
either way we have had enough of the
constant whining and
bleating about how everything has been
fixed and rigged against this man to
whom the difficulties of inheriting a
fortune and a business are the
equivalent of the endless punishment of
bigotry against African Americans to
whom giving his money to his employees
is as big a sacrifice as a mother and
father losing their son in war to whom
the dating scene of the 1970s was his
Vietnam we have had enough of the casual
cruelty z' and the unthinking dholtze
who applauded them the boasts after the
dead in Orlando or on the streets of
Chicago or of the discovery of bombs in
New York we have had enough of the
throwaway insults towards veterans with
PTSD who committed suicide
the dishonest merchants boast that he
used the tax laws brilliantly while he
claims the half who do not make enough
to pay the taxes or harming the country
we have had enough of the attacks on
every journalist every columnist every
news organization unless their news
organization has recently run a poll
favorable to him we have had enough of a
political party that elected a president
as late as 2004 and did not stop this
man and now even now will not repudiate
him and we will remember their names
not just the husband's like Newt
Gingrich and Rudy Giuliani and Rush
Limbaugh but the collaborators like
Kellyanne Conway and chris Christie and
Mike Pence and Sean Hannity and the
enablers like Joe Scarborough and
Senator Zayat and McConnell and a
previously esteemed figure who made a
fateful and fatal bargain named speaker
Paul Ryan we have had enough of the
vanity candidates and those who might as
well vote for Trump if they could
seriously consider voting for Gary
Johnson who cannot name any foreign
leaders or for Jill Stein a well-meaning
simpleton who stands for many good
things all of which she will watch die
before her eyes if she drains away
enough votes to get Trump elected we
have had enough liberals and
conservatives and everybody in between
of the prospect that all we take pride
in
all we have inherited all we have built
upon can be threatened by a third-rate
demagogue with a cult-like following
whose members have turned off the
reality switch in their heads and who
got out of school somehow without being
able to know the difference between the
true the possible and the imaginary we
have had enough of the morons who
snapped cellphone photos of reporters
and promised retribution against them
who believed the failures of their own
lives will be corrected for them by this
Thanksgiving Day Parade balloon in a
suit who would and will sell them out at
the first opportunity and bring all but
a handful of them a new America that
will make the one they are whining about
now see me in retrospect and even to
them like heaven upon the earth we have
had enough and we are angry and we are
angry not because our personal desires
have been thwarted like a crowd of third
graders who are told they can't have all
the candy we are angry because this
country is under attack from within by a
man and the groups behind him who care
nothing for the freedoms of this country
who do not want everybody to have a
chance who insists they should have
everything and the rest should have
nothing but ours is the righteous anger
of the invaded of the attacked of those
subverted against it is our job to
protect the freedom and in the next
month it is a simple equation for all
the other freedoms to survive in this
country our great country our country
which at its worst already is great for
us to remain free we must be free of
Donald Trump I do not think I am
boasting and I do not think I'm telling
you anything you don't know already when
I say that I remain perhaps the leading
media figure identified with the
criticism of the administration of
president george w bush this is very
simple his father George HW Bush
reportedly will vote for Hillary Clinton
his second homeland security chief
Michael Chertoff wants head of the
Republican Council on the Whitewater
Committee which tried to prosecute
Hillary Clinton has endorsed Hillary
Clinton and bluntly
were it the choice I would sooner and
happily vote for a third term of George
W Bush rather than five minutes of
president Donald Trump Donald Trump is
the scum of the earth and the only way I
would not believe that Donald Trump is
the scum of the earth is if Donald Trump
himself told me he was the scum of the
earth because then I would know he was
lying about it and somebody else was the
scum of the earth we have had enough
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watched this space